الصلح بين اصاله وانغام شيرين عبد الوهاب
معنوياتها مرتفعه ودوي اسطوري بين محمد
عبده ولارا فابيان اليكم الابرز في
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسبوع بعد سنوات من القطيعه تم الصلح
اخيرا بين اصاله وانغام امام عدسات
الكاميرات وباركه تركي ال
الشيخ حدث ذلك في حفل ليله نجمات العرب
التي شهدتها الرياض بمناسبه راس السنه
ليله احيتها احلام اسماء المنور اصاله
انغام اليسا ونانسي عجرم وحققت تفاعلا
كبيرا على منصات التواصل ما فيش حجي كده
اه حبيبي كده وجع زي
زمان نجمات المشاركات في الحفل قدمنا
مختارات من اشهر اغانيه وكرمنا مغنيات
عربيات راحلات تركنا بصمه في تاريخ الغناء
العربي ولا
[موسيقى]
قرا
سالر
[موسيقى]
يا تداول محبو المطربه المصريه شيرين عبد
الوهاب على نطاق واسع مقاطع من الحفل الذي
احيته في راس السنه بدبي ظهرت فيها
بمعنويات مرتفعه بعد طلاقها بحسب تعليقات
بعض المتابعين على منصات التواصل شيرين
احيت الحفل بالشراكه مع نجوى كرم وسلطان
الطرب جورج
[موسيقى]
وسوف ومن الاخبار السعيده المبكره لهذا
العام اعلان الفنانه العراقيه رحمه الرياض
عن حملها وذلك في منشور عبر حسابها الرسمي
على انستغرام شاركته مع زوجها الفنان
الكسندر علوم كما نشر الفنان المصري تامر
حسني صوره طريفه مع عائلته بمناسبه العام
الجديد الصوره التي لم تشاركها بسمه بوسيل
اعطت انطباعا لمتابعي تامر انه عاد اليها
بعد انفصالهما العام الماضي ولم يصدر اي
تعليق رسمي من الطرفين ينفي صحه عوده
الثنائي او يؤكده
طيبتي
والعفو عند
القدره مدت لك
ين
تصفحك ونختتم الابرز باحتفال موسم الرياض
الاسبوع الماضي باليوبيل الماسي للفنان
السعودي محمد عبده احتفال اقيم على مدى
ليلتين بمسيره فنان العرب الممتده ل 60
عاما وشهدت الليله الاولى تقديم دوو وصف
بالاسطوره جمع بين محمد
والمغنيه لارا
[موسيقى]
فابيان قالت
منت مجموعه
انسان وكرم فنان العرب قوانه ذهبيه تبرع
بثمنها لحمله العاهل السعودي لاغاثه اطفال
غزه
ه